2021's mortal kombat may be a faithful
video game movie but it still makes some
major changes to the game's classic
combatants
here are all the major differences
between the characters in the games and
the movie
sub-zero has become a standard bearer of
the mortal kombat series to the point
that the phrase mortal kombat likely
conjures his enigmatically masked face
in many fans minds he's appeared as a
playable fighter in every single new
mortal kombat game since the very first
one arrived in arcades in 1992
so it makes sense that sub-zero freeze
blasts his way onto the silver screen as
the 2021 movie's primary villain but
there's a little detail about this
cinematic sub-zero most viewers aren't
going to pick up on
which reveals him to be a different
sub-zero than the one featured in the
modern slate of mortal kombat games
sub-zero begins the movie under his
given name bihaan but bihan is not these
sub-zero most mortal combat players know
and love
unless their frame of reference is
firmly rooted in the early 90s
indeed bihan is the original sub-zero
featured in the very first mortal kombat
game but in that inaugural game scorpion
kills bihan
in subsequent entries his younger
brother kwai liang takes up the sub-zero
mantle
it is qui liang rather than bihan who
appears as sub-zero in pretty much every
game since 1993's mortal kombat 2. the
exception to this occurs in the 2011
mortal kombat game in which both
versions of the character are featured
scorpion's origins are humble his first
design is exactly the same as sub-zeros
save for his yellow color scheme since
those early days however scorpion has
gone on to become one of the most
iconic mortal kombat characters around
second only to his icy counterpart he
goes by his birth name hanzo hisashi for
most of the 2021 movie
and isn't featured as heavily as many
fans might have been expecting
in fact he dies in the prologue and
doesn't reappear until he gets his
revenge on sub-zero in the final minutes
of the film
there are two key differences between
scorpion and the new mortal kombat movie
and scorpion in the mortal kombat games
in the first game as in the movie
scorpion is driven to hunt down sub-zero
after the cryomancer kills his family
or so he believes according to the
game's lore it is actually another realm
demon quan chi who commits the atrocious
killing but scorpion doesn't learn this
until multiple entries later
related to this point is the second key
difference between the cinematic
scorpion and his game bound counterpart
the movie introduces a major
new twist to his origin a surviving heir
in 2021's mortal kombat hanzo's youngest
daughter manages to survive the massacre
and goes on to continue a bloodline that
eventually results in the birth of
coal aside from newbie cole and his
family sonia blade is the only classic
mortal kombat character to get a brand
new character arc in the 2021 film this
movie brings a new facet to the complex
lore of mortal kombat the dragon mark
the dragon mark is a small brand in the
shape of the mortal kombat logo and is
what designates fighters as combatants
and gives them their arcana based powers
cole is born with his dragon mark but
many of the movie's fighters earn theirs
in the only other way a person might
hope to do so they kill someone who
already has the mark when we meet sonia
early on she
is unmarked any mortal kombat fan could
tell you that it's not a group of earth
realm protectors without sonia blade so
it's not a surprise that this state of
affairs doesn't last
this is the core of sonya's story in
mortal kombat her journey ends when she
takes the dragon mark from kano by
killing him with a pretty gnarly stab
through the head he's a suitable victim
for sonia given their long-running
rivalry in the mortal kombat games and
comics
kano as depicted in the 2021 movie is a
foul-mouthed mercenary who feels very
much in keeping with the spirit of the
game character with one notable
exception the vast majority of the
mortal kombat games storytelling
positions kano as the nemesis of sonia
blade and jax so it's a bit of a twist
to see him helping
liu king train cole in the 2021 film or
is it we hate to ruin the fun and
suspense but any mortal kombat fan worth
their salt can tell you that kano is the
master of betrayal without completely
giving away the details of the movie
let's just say that mortal kombat
delivers on kano and sonia blade's
rivalry and makes kano the lovable
scumbag he truly is
beauty another interesting difference
between kano of the movie and kano of
the games
lies in his status within the black
dragon clan in the current timeline of
the games kano is the group's leader but
in the new film he is merely a member
the only other thing missing is his
cybernetic heart which allows him to
shoot out blasts from his chest to
annihilate his foes
hopefully we'll be seeing a little of
that action in subsequent mortal kombat
movies
of all the main characters featured in
2021's mortal kombat jax
is the only fighter who isn't part of
the first game's roster
introduced in mortal kombat 2 special
forces agent jax briggs instantly
immortalized himself and has appeared as
a playable character in almost every
mortal kombat game
since unless you haven't touched the
series since his introduction in mk2 you
probably noticed something off about jax
at the start of the movie or to be
specific
to things that's right in the movie jax
has normal human arms
ever since mortal kombat 3 jax has been
known best for his titanium cybernetic
arms which allow him to go toe-to-toe
with dark sorcerers and
outright gods this might seem like a
shocking departure few fans would be
able to embrace
let alone get excited about but consider
this now we get to see this
transformation happen
in all its gory glory in this rendition
of the mortal kombat story it is
sub-zero who brutally freezes and
dismembers jax he gets his shiny
synthetic limbs just in time to kick
plenty of outworld butt and absolutely
destroy reiko with his iconic headclap
fatality
a warrior monk and champion of
earthrealm liu kang
usually acts as the protagonist of the
mortal kombat game series
this was directly translated to film in
the original 1995 mortal kombat movie
the 2021 film and contrast introduces
cole young as the new main character
pushing liu kang into a mentor role this
is a serious departure from the much
larger role liu kang typically plays in
mortal kombat stories which is made even
more dramatic by the fact that this
chosen one takes a back seat to many
other major players in the film
liu kang's design in the 2021 movie is
inspired by his look in the early mortal
kombat games as is the case with many of
the film's other fighters noticeably
absent from his cinematic arsenal are
the nunchaku he uses as a weapon in the
playstation 2 trilogy of 3d mortal
kombat games those nunchaku were
recently brought back as kang's primary
weapon in 2019's mortal kombat 11.
anyone who has only checked out that
game will find lu kang's silver screen
fighting style to be quite different
from what they've come to expect
slicing through his opponents with its
unforgettable wide-brimmed hat
shaolin monk kung lao does a whole lot
of killing and
not much talking in 2021's mortal kombat
that's far from a complaint we're all
here for the action after all
the new movie thankfully takes most of
the boxes when it comes to this fan
favorite character
of course his iconic hat famously
inspired by alpha henchman odd jobs
topper in 1964's goldfinger is a bloody
tour de force but kung lao
also does plenty of teleporting
throughout the movie's runtime mentioned
two
is his lineage he is a descendant of the
great kung lao legendary champion of
earthrealm the 2021 film
also adds another new wrinkle to the
mythology of mortal kombat here
liu kang and kung lao are cousins
antagonist
shang tsung doesn't take up much screen
time at all in the 2021 film despite the
fact that he's liu kang's rival
and the main villain of the first mortal
kombat game in this movie the rivalry
between shang tsung
and liu kang isn't emphasized though
there is some groundwork laid for it in
a potential future movie
absent too is any mention of soon's
origin as a chinese human born in earth
realm who was given his powers over dark
sorcery by outworld emperor xiao khan
that's not where the differences end
either aesthetically the shang
tsung we see in the movie doesn't
resemble any of the shang tsungs we've
seen in the mortal kombat games
shangsung of the games is said to have
been based on lopan the villain of john
carpenter's beloved film
big trouble in little china in the 2021
mortal kombat film however shang tsung
is decked out in heavy armor that does
not remotely resemble the light robes he
started off wearing in the games the
only characteristics the mortal kombat
movie nails regarding shang tsung are
his shape-shifting abilities and his
insatiable thirst for human souls
your soul is mine braden doesn't get a
whole lot of time in the ring in the new
mortal kombat movie unless you count the
end where he lightning shocks
shang tsung back to outworld referred to
by liu kang
and kung lao only as lord raiden the god
of thunder
ends up in a similar place as shang
tsung does in this film taking a bit of
a back seat to the action
raiden is the leader and the eldest of
the earth realm protectors in the film
when it comes to the games however he's
a lot more important
raiden is one of the few characters who
makes an appearance in every mortal
combat game and he's playable in all of
them except mortal kombat 3. while this
god only has a small role in the film
his silver screen design definitely
resembles the raiden we see in most
mortal kombat games he's got his
defining straw hat and his unmistakable
robe ensemble
really it's all but identical to what he
sports in recent mortal kombat games it
would have been nice to see him flash
his moves while wearing these classic
duds but you can't have everything you
want even when you're a thunder god
a four-armed shokon from outworld goro
is one of the most instantly
recognizable mortal kombat characters
ever designed in the 1995 movie goro is
portrayed by actor tom woodruff wearing
a mind-boggling complex costume with
actors kevin michael richardson and
frank welker providing goro's speaking
voice and vocal effects respectively the
suit weighed roughly 125 pounds and was
operated through a complicated
combination of puppetry animatronics and
woodruff's own physicality though 1995's
goro looks dated to modernize it's hard
not to be impressed by the sheer volume
of practical effects work that went into
creating him the 2021 reboot and
contrast takes the opposite approach
going full
on cgi this new digitally smooth goro
gets an introduction and a short fight
scene that sees him go up against coal
not much is explained about goro in
mortal kombat and as a result plenty of
fun backstory is omitted
in the game series lore goro is the one
who killed the great kung lao
and sister to the hat throwing kung lao
of the main timeline this makes goro
a legendary warrior but such prestige
doesn't come across
at all in the 2021 film instead he feels
like a henchman
also noticeably absent to anyone who
mains goro in the game series are the
green fireballs he is known to shoot
from his arm and mouth
the single deepest cut the 2021 mortal
kombat movie makes in terms of
characters has got to be natara the
vampire from mortal kombat deadly
alliance
introduced in the fifth main game of the
series only ever appearing again as a
playable character in mortal kombat
armageddon natara was an inspired choice
to include in the movie yet the natara
of the silver screen is not exactly the
natara of the games most notably the new
movie makes a few modernizing edits to
her aesthetic
for starters her outfit is a lot less
revealing secondly her red bandana which
doubles as an eye patch for her left eye
is nowhere to be found
aside from her bat-like wings natara's
signature look rests upon the bandana
and the charm she wears around her neck
which allows her to warp between realms
both of these defining accessories are
completely missing from the film
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you